pendant vos vacances vous avez peut-être
pratiquer ce nouveau sport un sport qui
commence à faire parler de lui
un sport dans le vent la planche à voile
ils sont de plus en plus nombreux à le
pratiquer sur les plages c'est à dinard
sous un très beau soleil que se sont
disputées les deuxième régate open
international de planche à voile
le but de cette opération réunir enfin
les différentes marques dans une même
compétition huit pays représentés avec
une très forte participation allemande
et française
deux épreuves au programme deux heures
de course samedi et 5 heures c'est
d'après midi deux concurrents par
planche et 112 planches au départ
un départ très spectaculaire regarde
comme aux 24 heures du mans
un départ superbe avec quelques
problèmes pour certains concurrents en
tout cas un très beau sport que nous
avons découvert à l'occasion de cette
manifestation organisée par nicolas
hulot qui donne quelques précisions aux
futurs amateurs de planche à voile
on planche ça va deux mille francs à
9000 francs la bonne moyenne ces 3500
francs pour 3500 francs on peut avoir
une courge courait alors une planche et
se sait exactement à une planchette une
planche de surf un peu plus grande avec
un mât et une voile de su monter sur un
cardan sur la planche donc la voile est
libre dans toutes les directions sur la
planche et le l'équipier c'est à dire le
planchiste fait office de haubans et de
safran et c'est lui qui dirige que tient
le mât il fait tout donc c'est l'agilité
la force musculaire qui remplace sont
descendus sous les bras qui travaillent
c'est surtout les bras qui travaillent
mais auparavant comme ça vous verrez que
les concurrents auront mal des bouts des
doigts au bout des doigts de pied il ya
quelques équipages féminins
alors écoutez en passive il ya quelques
équipages féminins
comment expliquer justement la réussite
de ce
nouveau score devrait coûter beaucoup de
gens qui sont là faisait du dériveur
avant ledit river il faut toujours avoir
un équipier avec soin et ici vous pouvez
en faire sur n'importe quel plan de
l'enfer près de paris on peut en faire
dans l'ensemble de la france on peut en
faire partout et en plus ça demande des
qualités physiques que tout le monde a
et quand on fait de la planche on a
vraiment une sensation de liberté
extraordinaire
on peut parler de bientôt d'un futur
championnat de france le championnat de
la fédération française de voile est
présente à notre épreuve pour tenter
pour l'an prochain de mettre au point
des règles de jauge parce que là vous
avez des planches qui font trois mètres
20 à 3 mètres 80 donc l'an prochain à la
fédération
il sera avec où je pense qu'elle a remis
au point des règles de jauge et à ce
moment là au niveau fédéral peut-être
que l'année proche ira lui a même
épreuve l'an prochain ça perd un
championnat d'europe après la course
d'hier et l'époque de cet après midi au
classement général 1er feu des radios en
suède 2e marion nieuwbourg france à
signaler l'excellent comportement de mon
confrère de l'équipe gilles permis
agon
hull